[Música]
Hola Soy Gabriel callen y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magazine quincenal de France 24 en el
que acercamos a América Latina las
historias de medio oriente Y esto es lo
que veremos hoy
en Irán lucen envenenamientos de niñas
por gas en las escuelas han recrudecido
con llamas de mil casos reportados a
través del país una situación muy
preocupante para las familias muchos
acusan al gobierno de estar detrás de
estos actos estaremos analizando el tema
con nuestra invitada
en Israel La Explanada de las mezquitas
fue una vez más el origen de
enfrentamientos entre las autoridades
israelíes y los palestinos cohetes
fueron disparados entre Israel y la
franja de gaza e incluso Líbano veremos
Por qué la mezquita alaxa es tan
simbólica y sensible
finalmente hablaremos de jimen donde un
acuerdo sobre el intercambio de
centenares de prisioneros ha sido
concluido entre los Rebeldes sushis y
las autoridades y bienvenidos es un
canje que hace crecer las esperanzas de
paz en el país
empezamos en Irán porque desde algunos
meses una macabra práctica se ha
extendido por algunos colegios femeninos
del país el envenenamiento de niñas con
un tipo de gas
desconocido se ha vuelto frecuente miles
de menores han reportado mareos y
problemas respiratorios mientras partes
de la población acusa al gobierno el
régimen teocrático ha detenido a más de
100 personas a los que llama enemigos
del país para analizar el tema estuvimos
hablando con nazis una residente en
España y promotora de derechos humanos
que nos explicó Qué se sabe de lo que
está ocurriendo en estos colegios
el tema de los envenenamientos en las
escuelas es un tema muy oscuro
es muy difícil obtener noticias certeras
porque
el régimen no ha permitido a los
periodistas poder documentar investigar
de hecho las detenciones que se han
anunciado hasta ahora parecen ser de
personas que han firmado los hechos
cuando pasaban cerca de una escuela y la
mayoría de los detenidos a raíz de estos
hechos son personas que han intentado
dar a conocer esta noticia
y parecía que se había extinguido un
poco pero ha vuelto a crecer de nuevo
los casos ha habido de las 31 provincias
que hay en Irán 28 están afectadas con
más de mil chicas afectadas
incluso ha habido algún fallecimiento y
es un tema realmente preocupante y que y
que las autoridades no logren aclarar
este tema porque es curioso como cuando
a la mínima Ven a una detectan a una
mujer sin velo como hace poco vimos que
un señor les echó yogur en la cabeza a
unas mujeres que llevaban sin velo las
detuvieron a las 24 horas O sea que se
puede encontrar a la gente pero en estos
en este caso no hay detenidos no hay
noticias y los que intentan dar las
noticias se les se les limita sus
libertades de expresión también le
preguntamos a quién se le acusa de estos
actos
Bueno hay diversas teorías hay quien
dice que es una especie de venganza
porque las escuelas han sido también un
hervidero de protestas digamos que la
generación del tiktok en Irán ya no
acepta las chicas ya no aceptan que se
les diga que son menos que los hombres
que no tienen los mismos derechos que no
se pueden expresar que no pueden ser
libres que
que no pueden vestirse como quieran eso
ya no no encaja no encaja y allí ha
habido movimientos desde niñas niñas de
9-10 años empezaron con las revueltas a
raíz del asesinato de masamini empezaron
también a unirse a todos estos
movimientos de protestas en las escuelas
sus profesores les han secundado muchas
veces pero bueno pues ya sabes que la
represión en Irán está siendo muy muy
fuerte muy tajante y bueno en un
principio se que se quieran callar la
voz de estas chicas y atemorizarlas para
que no no sigan
reclamando sus derechos esa es una de
las de las teorías hay alguna otra que
son grupos muy radicales
el gobierno suele siempre bueno el
régimen suele acusar siempre a Fuentes
extranjeras incluso a medios de
comunicación extranjeros
Así que
lo que está claro en este tema es que no
hay nada claro y que es un tema muy muy
oscuro y y que está
afectando mucho a la población a los
padres y las familias de estas chicas
finalmente si nos explicó Cómo
evolucionó el movimiento de protestas
que empezó después de la muerte de la
joven masamine
el tema de la de los el movimiento
comenzó con la muerte el asesinato de
masa mini pero ya no es solo más allá Es
son multitud de grupos y de personas una
gran parte de la población que está
descontenta los están participando muy
activamente y luego pues ya te he dicho
que hay minorías étnicas perseguidas los
sordos los baluch los profesores están
muy descontentos han salido también a
las calles
son multitudes y millones de personas en
el país que ya no con esta represión Y
sí que ha habido parece que se les ha
logrado callar un poco pero hay un
descol rescoldo ahí debajo de la brasa
que que va a salir en cualquier momento
Irán está es como una bomba a punto de
explotar
y la gente que vive allí la inmensa
mayoría que que quieren la libertad los
Derechos Humanos
creen y confían en que en que esto ya no
tiene vuelta atrás que Aunque parezca
que ya no hay mucho criterio por las
calles Esto va a volver incluso están
empezando a pedir que los hombres
acompañen a la protesta con las mujeres
llevando pantalón corto que tampoco les
dejan a los hombres
por lo que me cuentan es muy habitual
ver a muchísimas mujeres en la calle sin
el jabón
en un desafío a esta imposición Así que
todavía queda mucho que contar y mucho
que ver lo que va a pasar en Irán Pero
esto es una historia que va a avanzar
que ya no hay marcha atrás en este
movimiento por lo que se está
percibiendo seguimos en Israel la
Explanada de las mezquitas Ha sido un
escenario histórico de tensión entre
israelíes y palestinos porque coexisten
sitios de oración musulmanes y judíos en
los últimos días coincidieron la Pascua
judía y el ramadán lo que fue el
detonante de fuertes enfrentamientos los
nuevos choques en Jerusalén han escalado
a un intercambio de cohetes entre Israel
con milicias de gaza y Líbano y
atentados que han dejado varios muertos
y heridos además la policía de Israel
detuvo de manera violenta a decenas de
palestinos mientras rezaban en la
mezquita de alaxa lo que desencadenó en
fuertes reacciones en el mundo musulmán
Pero por qué la Explanada de las
mezquitas es un lugar tan sensible y
siempre foco de tensión es el tercer
lugar más sagrado del islam después de
la Meca y medicina en la rabia Saudita
se encuentra en Jerusalén en este la
parte Palestina ocupada y anexionada por
Israel desde 1967 y considerada por el
estado de Palestina como su propia
capital en la Explanada está erigida la
mezquita de alaxa que significa la más
lejana es el software you más distante
al que según la tradición musulmana
acudió el profeta Mahoma y también está
la cúpula de la roca otro sitio divino
para los musulmanes Mientras tanto este
mismo sitio es conocido por los judíos
como Monte del templo el lugar más
sagrado para ellos la Explanada fue
construida en el siglo vii sobre el
emplazamiento de lo que hubiera sido el
primer templo judío cuna de esta
religión pero destruido por los romanos
lo único que queda de este antiguo
templo judío es el muro occidental o
muro de las lamentaciones allí en los
195 metros de largo los judíos oran y
lamentan la pérdida del templo
parte de la comunidad judía tiene como
objetivo volver a construir su templo en
la Explanada lo que explica en parte
todas estas tensiones
mientras una fundación jordana gestiona
La Explanada es Israel quien proporciona
su seguridad según un estatus
establecido después de la guerra de 1967
el lugar está abierto a los turistas y a
los cristianos y los judíos durante unas
horas al día y cinco días a la semana
pero solo los musulmanes pueden rezar
allí los palestinos consideran este
lugar como el último vestigio de
Jerusalén que los israelíes no ocupan
pero temen que Israel planee algún día
apoderarse de ello por eso la Explanada
se ha transformado en un símbolo de la
lucha Palestina
y pasamos a yemen donde hay un
intercambio de centenares de prisioneros
lo que hace crecer las esperanzas de
volver a ver la estabilidad y la paz en
este país se trata de 181 prisioneros
progubernamentales detenidos por las
fuerzas uchis mientras ellos varios
sauditas a cambio de 7006 combatientes
retenidos por las fuerzas
gubernamentales es el intercambio más
importante desde el año 2020 el acuerdo
se alcanzó pocos días después de que a
raya Saudita e Irán reanudarán sus
relaciones diplomáticas después de siete
años de ruptura y está asumido en una
guerra civil desde el año 2014 entre las
fuerzas rebeldes
respaldadas por Irán y las fuerzas
apoyadas por las autoridades saúllitas
suñitas a rabia Saudita involucrada en
yemen desde 2015
estaría buscando Según analistas
consultados por varias agencias de
noticias una salida a la guerra o por lo
menos una estabilización del conflicto
en su frontera
las autoridades sauditas reanudaron las
conversaciones con Los Rebeldes y se
centraron en temas como el levantamiento
completo del bloqueo aéreo y marítimo La
retirada de todas las fuerzas
extranjeras de yemen y la liberación de
todos los prisioneros sin embargo llegar
a una paz durable en yemen sigue siendo
difícil de alcanzar por ahora
terminamos en Siria porque el presidente
basaga al azar está regresando poco a
poco a la escena internacional y
retomando su influencia en la región
tras años de aislamiento por la guerra
primero tu necesidad anunciaron el
restablecimiento de sus relaciones tras
casi 12 años de una ruptura diplomática
túnez había expulsado al embajador sirio
por la represión Sangrienta del
presidente
contra sus opositores por otro lado
Arabia Saudita también normalizó sus
relaciones con el país
riad estaría buscando reintegrar a
Damasco a la liga árabe una organización
regional en la que hay puntos
encontrados sobre el retorno de Siria
este año el presidente alasad viajó a
emiratos árabes Unidos y omán y el
Ministerio de exteriores Egipto estuvo
de visita en Damasco
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a seguir toda
la información en nuestra página web
France 24.com
[Música]